[Musica]
ci siamo mai chiesti perché ci siano un
frigo e un congelatore in ognuna delle
nostre case per raffreddare per
conservare
ci siamo mai chiesti se questi due
oggetti siano gli unici adatti a
conservare il cibo se siano gli
strumenti più efficaci ed efficienti per
farla
partiamo da una premessa fondamentale la
vita nel nostro pianeta si sviluppa tra
i 73 58 gradi centigradi e lo stesso
avviene nei batteri all'interno del
nostro cibo
se il cibo rimane all'interno di questa
fascia
i batteri ci sguazzano e lo rendono in
salute per la nostra vita
di qui l'esperienza ci ha insegnato a
conservare il cibo senza l'utilizzo di
additivi chimici o naturali come le
spezie alti fuori di questa fascia di
temperatura
utilizzando il freddo la ghiacciaia
prima il frigo del freezer poi prendiamo
l'esempio di una lasagna la cuciniamo la
domenica dopo averla cucinata la
mettiamo in congelatore e la manteniamo
in congelatore bella fredda meno 18
gradi per qualche giorno arrivato il
mercoledì sera ora di cena estraiamo dal
congelatore la mettiamo in forno
la riscaldiamo la temperatura cui
usualmente mangiamo il cibo caldo che è
più o meno 65 gradi centigradi
quindi il freezer sembra uno strumento
fondamentale giusto forse no
durante un viaggio di lavoro nel 2010
con un mio socio e collega siamo partiti
osservando ciò che avviene all'interno
dei laboratori di pasticceria di tutto
il mondo il cioccolato conservato in un
normalissimo frigo non dura che qualche
giorno prima di rovinarsi prima di fare
quella patina bianca che probabilmente
tutti abbiamo visto
utilizzando invece delle macchine
apposite che non solo controllano in
modo molto accurato la temperatura ma
controllano anche l'umidità
il cioccolato viene conservato il
cioccolato si conserva in maniera
eccellente anche per mesi ci siamo
quindi chiesto se fosse possibile in
maniera del tutto analoga attraverso un
controllo preciso della temperatura e
dell atmosfera in cui il cibo rimane se
fosse possibile conservare cibo cotto
per una settimana a una temperatura al
di sopra di 58 gradi centigradi
una volta arrivati a destinazione ci
siamo convinti che tutto ciò era
fattibile abbiamo dato via dieci anni di
studi con l'università di parma per
trasformare la nostra domanda in una
convinzione
oggi questa convinzione si chiama
conservazione a temperatura di servizio
e abbiamo creato una start up si chiama
ex ever la cui missione è quella di
rendere questa tecnologia parte
integrante delle nostre vite di domani
conservazione a temperatura di servizio
significa conservare il cibo cotto a una
temperatura che che è la stessa alla
quale lo consumiamo ci consentirà di
cucinare mantenere il cibo caldo e
consumarlo senza mai passare dalle
temperature fredde ed è e dal successivo
riscaldamento risparmiando quindi tempo
ed energia e ci permetterà di farlo in
modo assolutamente sicuro perché forse
non tutti sappiamo che in un frigo i
batteri vengono molto rallentati diciamo
in inibiti ma solo alle alte temperature
vengono uccisi
se ci pensate è quello che facciamo da
decenni attraverso la pastorizzazione
oppure attraverso il trattamento ht del
latte abbiamo applicato questa
tecnologia moltissimi cv con risultati
assolutamente positive tranne pochissime
eccezioni
conserviamo carni pesci riso legumi e
tutti i loro prodotti come zuppe brasati
stufati lessi alcuni casi alcuni casi
per giorni in altri casi per settimane
con karakuri risultati organolettici
eccellenti e sempre con la massima
sicurezza alimentare senza l'utilizzo di
nessun additivo quella il futuro e le
applicazioni che immaginiamo per questa
tecnologia
penso che vi sarà sicuramente capitato
come è capitato media arrivare a tarda
notte in un ristorante in un
in un albergo e dovervi accontentare di
un paio di un po di dormire ottoline per
cena
vi siete mai domandati perché mantenere
una cucina attiva 24 ore su 24 è un
costo che la maggior parte delle
strutture alberghiere non possono
permettersi soprattutto quelle più
piccole quelle che invece già oggi
stanno utilizzando la conservazione a
temperatura di servizio sono in grado di
servire pasti giorno e notte senza avere
personale specializzato in cucina ci
consente quindi di ordinare cibo cotto
in ogni momento del giorno della notte e
in un futuro ci permetterà di trovare di
fianco al frigo bar un caldo bar dal
quale servizi direttamente nelle nostre
camere ogni volta che lo vogliamo quando
vado al ristorante soprattutto se lo
faccio per lavoro o con le mie bambine
mi aspetto di essere servito il più
rapidamente possibile i ritmi frenetici
della vita moderna hanno imposto ai
ristoratori di cambiare il proprio menù
andando verso preparazioni molto più
veloci e abbandonandosi vede la
tradizione o in alternativa cucinare con
anticipo è di nuovo congelare e poi
riscaldare magari quando c'è poco tempo
in microonde con risultati non sempre
eccellenti i ristoranti che già oggi
stanno utilizzando la conservazione a
temperatura di servizio sono i vedo dt
sono invece in grado di servire
grandissimi quantità di cibo rapidamente
anche eliminando completamente tutti gli
sprechi dovuti a lisca non poter
utilizzare oggi quello che è stato di
nuovo riscaldato
tutto ciò che in conservazione oggi sarà
ancora buono domani tutto ciò che non
venderanno oggi domani sarà ancora
altrettanto buona per queste due prime
applicazioni abbiamo già creato un
prodotto si chiama ed aereo lo stanno
utilizzando chef stellati per provare
tempi di conservazione mai provati prima
e per semplificare la gestione delle
loro cucine lo stanno usando catene
della ristorazione per accelerare
moltissimo il tempo di servizio e quindi
aumentare la loro profittabilità e
ampliare la gamma della loro offerta
ma torniamo al futuro che immaginiamo in
stazione in aeroporto sicuramente avete
una volta almeno nella vostra vita
acquistato del cibo delle 20
machine tipicamente si tratta di cibo
freddo preconfezionato snack magari
molto buoni ma sicuramente non
alternativi a un pasto completo
quando invece anche le vende ma ci
saranno dotati di conservazione a
temperatura di servizio sarà possibile
acquistare anche in movimento anche in
una stazione anche in un aeroporto un
pasto caldo completo e consumarlo
rapidamente pasto caldo che potremo
portare con noi in ufficio e avercelo
pronto in ogni momento
in una pausa pranzo oppure in una
semplice pausa la tecnologia richiede
pochissima energia per funzionare e sarà
sufficiente avere una speciale borsa
termica uno speciale contenitore
alimentato da una semplicissima presa
anche usb per avere sempre pronto il
nostro pasto in ogni momento in cui ci
sarà possibile consumarla pasto caldo
che potremo acquistare direttamente al
supermercato di fianco al banco freezer
e frigo che oggi troviamo in tutti i
supermercati del mondo ci saranno dei
freak i caldi dal quale potremo
acquistare del cibo cotto e consumarlo
direttamente nel supermercato o portarlo
nelle nostre case
all'interno di due ore di trasporto
anche se si scende per poco tempo al di
sotto della temperatura di 58 gradi non
avviene rischio di proliferazione
batterica perché sostanzialmente il cibo
è già stato sterilizzato e in caso in
cui il trasporto durasse poco più fino
al limite di 6 ore comunque la
successiva permanenza in conservazione
garantisce l'assoluta sterilizzazione
del cibo come portare il cibo caldo
sullo scaffale del supermercato una
prima soluzione sarebbe quello di
cucinarlo direttamente nelle cucine dei
supermercati cosa che si trova in quelli
più grandi non alternativa che stiamo
già sperimentando e quella di cucinare
il cibo all'interno di cucine
professionali oppure addirittura
l'industria alimentare e trasportarlo
poi con dei contenitori caldi o
addirittura con dei rimorchi di camion
dotati di tecnologie di conservazione a
temperatura di servizio
con enormi vantaggi energetici perché
potremo sfruttare la stessa energia e lo
stesso calore prodotto dalla motrice
invece che consumare ulteriormente
produrre ulteriori inquinamento per
tenere a bassa temperatura
il rimorchio del camion di fianco alla
catena del freddo che tutti conosciamo
cui i cibi si muovono a basse
temperature
nel futuro che immaginiamo ci sarà una
catena del caldo in cui cibi si
muoveranno ha tenuto ad alte temperature
l'applicazione più sfidante per questa
tecnologia e per la catena del caldo
sarà sicuramente la distribuzione di
cibi in zona affetti da disastri
naturali oppure da guerre in caso di
crisi diventa urgente trasportare
materie prime
cucine e personale in prossimità della
zona di crisi per produrre e distribuire
pasti
il che spesso si scontra non solo con le
diffide difficoltà logistiche ma anche
con la difficoltà di trovare un numero
sufficiente di volontari professionisti
disposti a lasciare per settimane le
loro famiglie creando invece dei
container dotati di console di
conservazione a temperatura di servizio
sarà possibile mantenere le cucine il
personale in prossimità delle loro case
e trasportare poi il cibo caldo ed avere
in loco solo il personale ha detto la
sua distribuzione ma l'applicazione di
gran lunga più ambiziosa è quella da cui
siamo partiti le nostre case il nostro
sogno è che così come frigo e freezer
costituito e costituiscono delle
tecnologie che diamo per scontate nella
nostra vita di oggi la conservazione a
temperatura di servizio sia una
tecnologia scontata nella nostra vita di
domani ci consentirà di avere in ogni
momento del giorno e della notte un
pasto caldo sempre pronto per il consumo
pasto caldo che potremmo acquistare in
un supermercato ordinare ad un
ristorante farselo portare a casa con il
servizio di home delivery o direttamente
cucinarlo nelle nostre cucine tornando
all'esempio della lasagna da cui siamo
partiti ci consentirà di cucinare queste
lasagna la domenica pomeriggio inserirla
nel reparto caldo del nostro frigo
arrivati mercoledì sera al momento della
cena tutto ciò che dovremo fare sarà
prelevare la lasagna metterla in tavola
e consumarla assieme alle nostre
famiglie
questa è la conservazione a temperatura
di servizio
questa ex ever questo sogno che ci
stiamo impegnando a far diventare realtà
[Applauso]